[Musique]
les comptes-rendus d'échographie tous
les comptes rendus j'ai tout gardé c'est
important parce que je en fait c'est les
seules preuves tangibles qui restent de
la distance de mes bébés il s'appelait
Maya Alice et Raphaël les bébés de Julie
ont bel et bien existé mais sont décédés
avant que sa grossesse arrive à terme
comme elle chaque année des milliers de
familles y sont touchés par le deuil
périnatal un sujet encore très tabou en
France comme le reste du monde fait
comme si moi ça ne m'était pas arrivé je
ne peux pas prendre la parole et c'est
vraiment c'est ça en fait le déni du
deuil périnatal l'autre gros souci qu'on
a c'est qu'on a un gros problème avec la
mort des bébés et des enfants en général
c'est on n'a pas de mots dans la langue
française pour décrire un parent qui
perd son bébé ou son enfant la mortalité
périnatale est définie par le décès d'un
bébé entre la 22e semaine d'aménorrhée
et le septième jour de sa naissance
qu'il s'agisse de morts in utero
d'interruption médicale de grossesse ou
de décès néon précoce en France cela
représente plus de 10 grossesses sur
1000 et hier c'était la date
anniversaire de ma DPA de la date prévue
d'accouchement de mon premier bébé
maillage j'ai fait un poste pour lui
rendre hommage julie a créé un compte
Instagram pour briser le silence et
partager des conseils faut savoir que la
plupart du temps les messages blessants
ils viennent surtout d'incompréhension
moi je donne souvent des conseils très
pratiques du style éviter les petites
phrases comme vous en ferez d'autres
c'était pas un vrai bébé c'était pas un
vrai accouchement pour libérer la parole
et sensibiliser la société une journée
mondiale du deuil périnatal a été créée
le 15 octobre avec pour symbole ce ruban
bleu et rose l'association Agapa
accueille et accompagne les personnes en
souffrance suite à la mort d'un bébé
elle est aussi le personnel de santé à
mieux réagir face à ses drames je crois
que les soignants ils ont aussi grand
besoin de d'être accompagnés opposé un
temps ils peuvent se poser parce que
évidemment il ne vivent pas eux-mêmes
les d'être confronté à la souffrance
c'est éprouvant et que ils ont peu
d'espace aussi pour déposer ça
à Colombes l'association a aidé cette
hôpital à créer un espace de
recueillement pour les parents et les
soignants une initiative pour rendre
visible la réalité du deuil périnatal au
moins ils savent que ça existe et si on
leur en parle du coup ils seront
peut-être un peu plus ouverts peut-être
un peu moins gêné
après le besoin de reconnaissance
l'autre enjeu est de donner une
existence officielle au bébé décédé avec
la loi du 6 décembre 2021 un grand pas a
été franchi en accordant aux parents
d'un enfant né sans vie le droit de lui
donner un nom et de l'inscrire dans le
livret de famille
selon cette psychologue les parents
doivent pouvoir intégrer cet événement
dans leur parcours de vie comme la
société où l'entourage a tendance à leur
demander de pas
rester sur leur ressenti de passer à
autre chose à aller de l'avant ben du
coup il censure beaucoup aussi et c'est
des deuils potentiellement traumatiques
puisque c'est des situations dont on
peut avoir beaucoup de mal à cicatriser
en 2019 près de 6400 enfants sont nés
sans vie sur 748 il accouchement un
rapport de santé publique France pointe
le retard pris par le pays pour réduire
les décès de nourrissons car la
mortalité néonatale a augmenté de 25% en
10 ans les départements et régions
d'outre-mer sont particulièrement
touchées sur mille nouveaux-nés plus de
4 sont morts avant leur premier mois de
vie soit le double de la métropole
[Musique]
certains de ces drames peuvent-ils être
évités l'Agence nationale de santé
publique plaide pour un meilleur accès
aux droits et aux soins car la précarité
des nerfs est aggravée plus de femmes
sont en situation irrégulière et sans
abri au moment de donner la vie rien
qu'en Île-de-France le nombre de mers à
la rue a été multiplié par 4 en 10 ans
d'autres pistes pourraient expliquer
l'augmentation de la mortalité néonatale
comme l'âge maternel plus élevé et le
nombre de femmes enceintes en surpoids
on a quasiment un quart des femmes qui
ont 35 ans ou plus à l'accouchement
l'IMC donc l'indice de masse corporelle
effectivement augmentent aussi et
surtout quand on cumule les deux on
augmente encore les risques de
complications à l'accouchement de
complications au cours de la grossesse
autre facteur de risque de morbidité
maternelle la consommation d'alcool et
de tabac en France 16% des femmes
déclarent fumées pendant leur grossesse
l'un des plus hauts taux d'Europe au CHU
de Nantes le professeur Jean-Christophe
rosé évoque lui une pénurie de
personnels sans précédent qui s'est
aggravé depuis la crise du covid-19 le
travail de nuit la suggestion des gardes
et de plus en plus mal supporté par les
plus jeunes médecins donc il fut les
spécialités à garde on avait obligé de
s'adapter à cela parce qu'effectivement
une partie de la population est très
attachée à coucher tout près de chez
elle pensant que là était la sécurité or
on n'a plus les moyens c'est pas un
problème de moyens financiers c'est un
problème de moyens humains
d'organisation moi j'appelle les
autoritaires mettre un pilote dans
l'avion de la périnathalogie
en France le décret qui régit le
fonctionnement des maternités n'a pas
été changé depuis
1998 la profession souligne l'urgence de
l'actualiser pour rendre les postes de
soignants plus attractifs et travailler
en sécurité